you want to talk about gwen berry the
olympic hammer thrower who turned away
from the flag during the national anthem
yes
uh this is a really interesting story
because obviously it's it's uh
being uh played a bunch on fox news
these are people
hey look there's somebody who doesn't
care about the anthem and they're
turning away and blah blah blah so
basically in short the
u.s olympic trials not the olympics the
olympic trials had
uh their events over the weekend and
this girl gwen berry
is a hammer thrower and is like super
prolific she competed in one olympics
before and this is her like second time
going to the olympics she got bronze
in the olympic hammer throw and on the
podium she got up there
as they start playing the national
anthem which is a little unusual at the
olympic trials normally they just play
it once in the day and this is the one
time she
played it the one time they played it
was when she was on the podium just
happened to be when she was on the
podium yeah
not according to what she would say well
and then as they're playing the national
anthem she feels upset that they're
playing it while she's on the podium so
she turns
her back to the flag pretty much not in
necessarily like a super dramatic way
but like she kind of shuffles her feet
and like turns away from the flap
yeah and she also had a shirt that said
athlete activist on
yeah so uh i guess she's upset
she felt like she was set up because she
planned obviously she wore the athlete
activist shirt or brought it up there
she planned i guess to like put that up
and then
they start playing anthem and she's
probably going that moment like [ __ ] if
i put this up during this time
is it gonna look like i'm denying the
the anthem
or is it disrespecting the anthem or
whatever it is um
but then she turns away from it yeah
which is even worse
or looks even worse and of course you
know right-wing media jumps all over it
um but it's an interesting discussion
right because one
that anthem just gets played once
throughout the day there's many
different people that are going on
podiums and usually they plays once and
they played it five minutes after
the time it was supposed to so in their
uh defense
they're meaning like the olympic
committee's events was like yeah it was
it was a little bit late
we didn't plan this whole thing around
the [ __ ] female hammer throwing
yeah thing like you got a third place at
the third place oh she's third place
yeah yeah
hey face the flag yo
you let down the whole country why don't
you look at that flag [ __ ] it was there
was a trial so everyone it was all
american
but that's the thing that's why you
don't have to play it every single time
because
we know you're american so we knocked
this out once right um
but what i think is really interesting
about this is if you don't like america
don't represent it
in the olympics that america the
olympics is about representing your
country
that is the only thing it's about it is
a competition between countries
yeah but it's also about individual
greatness no it's it's
it's about individual greatness attached
to a country and you can
represent you can like um the the
olympic committee flag
yeah go for the olympic committee flag
so you're essentially going for
whatever it is you're not going for a
country even though
your country is represented in the
olympics but
yeah like that's what it's about i mean
if you look at the standings at the end
of the olympics it's like who had the
most medals yeah what's the middle count
but my point was like usain bolt is
attached to jamaica but he's bigger than
jamaican track star
absolutely yeah absolutely that's why i
think you would go
but in that case you could just rep the
bigger than that because
he got the stage of the world stage of
the olympics you could just do the world
champions
championships yeah right like just yeah
but the olympics has the most eyeballs
like if you want individual greatness
you're still the best way to do it is
dominate the olympics can't you compete
for like the non-country teams yeah
that's what we're saying like yeah that
would be the solution but if jesse owens
won eight gold medals at the goodwill
games
not that big but also she's getting mad
at this situation what would have
happened
if she qualifies and now is representing
america at the olympics she's gonna
not what's she gonna do when the flag is
raised then
yeah she's gonna turn turn away like and
here's the thing that's interesting at
the olympics
at the olympics you're not allowed to do
any demonstrations during the olympic
committee the american olympic committee
said you're not allowed to do any
demonstrations during the
podium thing right but during the
qualifying you are so she's technically
allowed to do whatever during this
i just find it weird like it's just
weird if you don't want to represent
america then just don't compete for
america
compete with the olympic flag that's
cool yeah but do you want to use all the
funding that the
olympic committee is going to give you
you want to use like there's it's not
like
it's not like there's not resources
right that america is giving you so you
can be great at this thing
so you're willing to take the american
resources so that you can be great
and then when it's time to represent
america who gave you those resources
you're like nah i don't [ __ ] with it
yeah just don't use the resources
started gofundme people would give to
that
yeah just off the strength but maybe i'm
missing something al what do you think
i don't know it's uh it's a little weird
that this was her way of demonstrating
because they started to play the anthem
like i would say hey
you're still doing the same thing that
you planned on doing with the t-shirt
so like now it it makes it look worse
that it's like now it's like
i'm actively trying to say
yeah disrespecting yeah you could have
just stood up there with your t-shirt
and it would have had the same message
and people supported it or not playing
they would they'd be like
yo you're i don't really get the
motivation that's the thing that
frustrates me is like i think she
should be allowed to protest if she
wants to yeah like it's i agree with
your point like it's kind of goofy blah
blah she's not going to protest the
funding blah blah blah
but the fact that she says that it's
some sort of like calculated conspiracy
to try to
you know attack her i think is like
completely misguided in like
borderline narcissistic borderline like
you're a hammer throw i don't even know
what a hammer i don't know what the
sport is i don't know what you're saying
that's the one where you put the ball
here and you spin no it has a chain
and the has a chain in the ball
but i i i don't know what happened we
gotta do away with some of these sports
yeah
it's too many it's like somebody's
supposed to gotta go well we just need
to make sure there's enough where we win
that's how it works yeah just keep
basketball no but that's why we have
like 50 different stuff i think like
hammer and shot put are like the
original sports from like
greek times anything we're good at we
have an advantage in we just
increase the amount of it so for example
they'll be like uh basketball really
good well let's add three on three
two three they're swimming we're really
good so we have a million different
strokes how many different strokes do
you need
let's just get there and back like we
don't have a million different ways to
run
we don't have high knee running low knee
running yeah yeah right you just
swim the fastest hurdles
relays yeah but that's not a different
way of actually moving
yeah right you could do longer like that
realistically in swimming it should just
be crawl stroke
but they have butterflies we should have
seven different basketballs we should do
3v3 we should do one on one we should do
a dunk contest
but like isn't swimming dumb think about
that like you should just swim the
fastest way if it's about speed
yeah yeah freestyle just freestyle right
like there's no pitch until basketball
like everybody's gotta play pigeon toad
or let's go backwards basketball white
guy basketball boycott well yeah
that's four that's not bad three on
three give us a chance of course
yeah we just play horse but we'll just
invent sports so we have an advantage in
like the overall metal account yeah and
they're always the sports that we're
good at right they're never the [ __ ]
that we're not that good at yeah which
makes sense
yeah wait bobsled [ __ ] that we don't
need more than one bobsled
no what's the point what are you doing
with this 200 meter bobsled 400
bobsley we got surfing this summer
coming up
yeah that's right that's what that got
added or that was always in it i think
it added
they have skateboarding yeah that's good
actually skateboarding is gonna be
really interesting
they're trying to like modernize like
they basically cannibalize the x games
when you think about it
the x game is is like the breeding
ground it's like the the g-league
for the olympics yeah and if something
impacts uh culturally enough
they're like all right boom we got that
now it's fine and then all the kids go
i'd like to watch the olympics yeah and
if you're a [ __ ] skateboarder if
you're niger
what's your name yeah nigel houston like
don't you want a gold medal dude
absolutely that'd be [ __ ] sick i'd
much rather have an
x-games [ __ ] trophy you're an
olympian
you're a [ __ ] olympian yes i'm going
to the [ __ ] village
yeah and it's not like you have to be in
like shape shape to stand he came out
with the body issues out there
what happened you saw that niger houston
came out with the i think sports
illustrated like body issue
son that's right before perfect with a
nice ass bro
nice ass did he show peace at all no
peace but perky buns with the tattoos
but here's your peas
not not full pecs no well he might get
cracked open if he's just selling ass
dude
yeah maybe tokyo those are the nah he's
jamaican right those are your beginning
dicks
yeah no not just jamaican he's not
[ __ ] with that oh you think he oh
that's right that's right his dad was
like rastafarian i think big time rasta
yeah
that's why he had dreads like he was
skating with dreads down like his feet
when he was like 10 years old
oh i didn't know that yeah that was
legit
oh [ __ ] that's kind of cool yeah he's
american but his parents are jamaican i
mean like where in america
like new york i think he grew up in
south florida or something but now he
lives in california
yeah l.a boy you're killing it but he's
nice like he's
the best of ever ever like unbelievable
and looks really interesting yeah like
tattoos everywhere
which is crazy if your skateboarder like
i'd be so worried i was going to scrape
my arm and [ __ ] the tattoo up
yeah is there no concern about like are
you worried about that i don't think
they're thinking long term he might be
covering up scars too
like yeah i mean he's like my whole body
i've just got scars everywhere like
let me get blasted and then worst case
scenario i can touch up my little
my like his ass kicks out let me get
blessed
um oh yeah so back to this girl but yeah
apparently the olympic committee came
out and said the national anthem was
scheduled to play at 5 20 today as per
the schedule we didn't wait until the
athletes were on the podium for the
hammer throw awards
national anthems played every day
according to the previously published
schedule
so they're like the schedule says we
played this time right after the day
events going into the night events
the hammer throw was the last day event
yeah it's just turning your back on it
if that's what you feel cool but it does
take away from any message you're trying
to have because it gives people
like i use the term the off-ramp to stop
caring about anything you're trying to
make us care about because now you're
disrespecting our flag
and whether it's right or wrong it does
turn off a lot of people
so if you're trying to get your message
out it's not your fault you should be
allowed to do that but
just share marketing you're turning off
a lot of potential consumers in whatever
your message but it's not disrespecting
the flag like
i don't like when people say that
because i'm like if you're not stepping
on or burning or pissing off
okay what is that it's the symbolic
nature of what you're doing
like in that moment no but each of those
athletes is representing a person like
this is completely opposite from
anything about kneeling in the other
leagues i'm like that's a business and
they're making money there's a trade
right there this is something where
tax the argument is this tax dollars go
to these olympic foundations we're
funding you
we are sending you who are exceptional
at that sport to represent
meat that is literally the trade of
services
that's it i pay you or provide funding
so you could get good at this sport
and then you go represent america so we
can look like we're dominating the world
and if you don't like that very open
relationship like we are open about what
that relationship is if you don't like
that and don't want to participate in
that that is totally fine
america allows you that freedom to not
do it but
some people might say it's hypocritical
to take that funding from america to
take those opportunities from america
and then after taking those things not
fulfill your obligation which is
representing america in the competition
and i think that's reasonable yep
you're breaking your deal you know what
i mean her statement was they said they
were going to play before we walked out
then they played it when we were out
there i don't really want to talk about
the anthem because that's not important
the anthem doesn't speak for me it never
has
that's fine if it doesn't but if that is
your
like obligation as far as like the
contract goes
then i think that's something that you
upkeep or you decide not to do it
i mean like you know you're a hammer
thrower
right like you know it's over after this
yeah right it's not like you're going to
go into the the professional women's
league
e3 college basketball like it's over
this is as far as you get yeah right and
then you work in a home depot
that's it right like that's it
so i don't know i mean i understand her
frustration
like i get where like the anger is
coming from but at the same time it's
like
yeah what frustration i mean she's like
frustrated with like that's what her
statement was like i only care about
systemic racism like it's bigger than
the sport like i'm not i'm here for my
community blah blah blah
blah blah blah don't compete in the
olympics then and also
you're not going to find a country
that's not racist systemically yeah why
is it you're competing
in you're competing in a competition
with a bunch of
racist countries like think about it
olympics is kind of inherently racist
super racist the whole point is like yo
let's see who's faster mexicans are
black people
playing the anthem doesn't undercut your
message of fighting systemic racism
because i think her point would be i
don't hate america i just have problems
with america
so to that end playing the anthem when
i'm on stage doesn't well on the podium
doesn't
take like doesn't put anything on me
that i hate yeah that's what i see
i i i also 100
true but i also don't want this to
become a big story because if this
becomes a big sorry annoying
well not only that now if you don't pro
if if people start saying you can't
protest the the the flag
yeah now the over correction happens
where every black olympian and it's the
summer olympics
so there's a lot has to do something to
protest the flag
or they're a sell out to black people in
the black struggle
so if i'm the olympic committee i say
sweetheart do whatever you want you can
express yourself this is
awesome like you go do it because we do
not want that to happen
when it comes olympic time the last
thing you want is all the people
representing your country looking like
even if that's not what they're trying
to say looking like they hate your
country
yeah and we definitely don't want white
people running a hundred meters
so we're gonna have to figure something
out with black people yeah okay let's
get this compromise
[Applause]